and wearing the traditional Shaw as you
can see I like it it's a very
respectable look and I need to uh
upgrade my
respectability they told me that be
careful kage is a place with this high
crime yeah so I was carrying a stick
around I
think I think I was I was misled
carrying a
stick this is a vlog of my stay in
Islamabad I've been here in Pakistan now
for effectively 2 weeks
went to Karachi went to laor and now
we're finishing off in Islamabad it's
been back toback been doing lots of
events uh extremely exhausting mentally
fatiguing got sick a couple of times but
you know what I said to myself this
place is Abad is actually a very
interesting place so I want to give you
a bit of a taste of Islam Abad by
showing you some of the things that I've
done hopefully you enjoy look at this
beautiful Islam Abad masallah so what's
the name of this uh Mara Hill marala
Hills marala Hills now this is nice you
know a plane crashed in this this
mountain really up there a plane crashed
a passenger plane crashed up there
really why how come this was about 10
years ago what is this where are we now
okay do sorry sorry carry
on this is Islamabad the city of
Islamabad and it's a clear day today it
was raining yesterday so it's not cloudy
anymore it's sunny and you can see uh
the beautiful city of Islamabad and this
is where the Himalaya range starts it
goes for thousands of miles all the way
up to the northern uh Northern
Territories of Pakistan where you find
some of the highest mountains in the
world K2 nanga purple the second two uh
highest mountains in the world are in
that region in this same mountain range
and it starts from the city of Islamabad
look at that beautiful sunset
now amazing
wow what an underrated City
Islam Abad there are places in hijab
there are places in Pakistan your breath
will stop Northern yeah you'll stop
breathing if you find this you'll be all
struck you'll be all you find this
beautiful you when you go to Northern
areas you'll be completely blown away
yes look at this gorgeous City M
absolutely amazing amazing and you can
see all the lights they've come on it's
m time almost and you can see the the
city lit
up cannot come to Pakistan and not enjoy
traditional Pakistani food that cannot
happens tells us social media that every
person in this whole world is just six
persons away from
everyone everyone
[Music]
six I in Islam Abad with the legend this
Islan we don't speak about how Islam
Abad could be an option for people to
actually live in we talk about Abu Dhabi
we talk about Dubai we talk about Doha
yeah we talk about turkey is but we
don't talk enough about s because it is
up there with these kind of options
brother I think so beautiful it's the
city has been developed from bottom up
it's beautiful because connected to the
mountains you got kind of like a Cape
Town feel they they manage it very well
if the whole of Pakistan was like itad
Pakistan would be like on a complet
levelo itad is an actual viable option
for someone who wants to live in a
country not in the west and still get
you know you can still speak and do da
and eat food and do this and that and
have good quality of life I think